COMING ON TONIGHT.
WELL IN THE MIDDLE OF THE LATEST
LeBRON JAMES CONTROVERSY,
BARSTOOL SPORTS IS NOW SELLING
THIS T-SHIRT.
CHAIRMAN JAMES.
DAVE PORTNOY FOUND A BAR STOOL.
HE IS NOW AN INTERNATIONAL BRAN
BRAND.
NOW HE JOINS US TONIGHT.
>> I'M NOT TO BE HOLDING TO
CHINA, TUCKER, BUT I'M TO BE
HONEST, I'M ONE OF THE GUYS THEY
GUARANTEED ME AND I MAY FALL IN
LINE LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE.
STEALING WHAT YOU ADMIT IT IF
YOU DO THAT THOUGH?
>> THAT'S A THING.
THAT'S WHAT DRIVES ME INSANE
WITH ALL OF THESE PEOPLE.
YOU HAVE TO ADMIT IT.
IF THEY SAID HEY, WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE A BILLION PEOPLE BY
T-SHIRTS, I WILL GO OUT AND PUT
MY HAND UP AND BE LIKE HEY, PUT
MONEY IN MY POCKET.
I DON'T AGREE WITH WHAT THEY'RE
DOING.
THAT'S WHAT DRIVES ME INSANE.
THE HYPOCRISY.
LeBRON, WHAT ARE YOU TALKING
ABOUT?
IT'S YOU WANTING TO BE A
BILLIONAIRE.
THAT'S IT.
END OF STORY.
>> Tucker: IT IS A LITTLE MUCH
TO LECTURE THE REST OF US IN
THIS COUNTRY ABOUT HER FEELINGS
WHILE AT THE SAME TIME REFUSING
TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE CHINESE
GOVERNMENT, WHICH IS PRETTY
DISGUSTING, HAS DONE
ANYTHING WRONG, EVER.
WHY DO THAT?
WHY NOT JUST BE QUIET ABOUT ALL
POLITICS?
>> I DON'T LIKE LeBRON JAMES.
I THINK HE'S A HYPOCRITE AND I
VOICE ABOUT.
WHEN I SAW WHAT HE TWEETED OUT,
I RAN TO MY COMPUTER.
I COULDN'T BELIEVE HE SAID IT.
JUST KEEP YOUR MOUTH SHUT.
HOW TONE -- YOU HAVE TO BE?
WHEN YOU PUT THE TWEETS THAT HE
HAS IN HIS PAST TOGETHER, IT
DOESN'T MATTER, BASIC HUMAN
RIGHTS AND THEN HE SAYS THE
EXACT OPPOSITE.
YOU CAN'T TALK.
SOME ISSUES YOU HAVE TO BE
QUIET.
IT LIKE AT THIS MOMENT --
I TALKED TO THEM THE WHOLE TIME
HERE HE IS A HYPOCRITE, HE WILL
SAY PEOPLE GO TO L.A. AND THEY
DON'T CARE ABOUT BASKETBALL,
THAT'S WHY THEY --
HE'S A HYPOCRITE.
HE DOESN'T LIKE TO MUCH PRESSURE
YET HE NAMED HIS KID
LeBRON JAMES JR. I MEAN,
EVERYTHING HE SAYS IS
HYPOCRITICAL.
THIS MAY BE THE ISSUE WHERE
PEOPLE FINALLY WAKE UP BECAUSE
LIKE YOU SAID, IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHAT SIDE OF THE ISLE YOU WERE
ON, DOESN'T MATTER.
EVERYBODY AGREES THIS IS ABOUT
BASIC DECENCY AND YOU CARE MORE
ABOUT YOUR MONEY AND BECOMING
ADULT BILLIONAIRE.
THAT'S IT.
>> Tucker: WHAT ABOUT HIS
HANDLERS AT NIKE?
CLEARLY HE IS TAKING OWNERSHIP
OF THEM, NO?
>> HERE'S WHAT I THINK HAPPEN.
I DON'T THINK HE'S EVER BEEN
TOLD NO AND HIS LIFE SO WHEN HE
TWEETED THAT OUT AND HE SAID
HEY, KING, THE HATERS DON'T LIKE
THIS, YOU MAY WANT TO JUST --
THEIR HATERS THOUGH.
THEY WILL NEVER TELL HIM HE DID
ANYTHING WRONG.
IT'S LIKE WHEN YOU'RE THE CHEVY
AT A SHAPE HEAVY CHAMP
HEAVYWEIGHT CHAMPION OF THE
WORLD.
I GUARANTEE YOU THEY PHRASES
LIKE WE ARE THE CRAZY ONES.
LIKE DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT, SOME
PEOPLE JUST GET ROUGH.
I GUARANTEE YOU HE HAS A HUGE
PSEUDO-APOLOGY STILL COMING.
HE HAS TO.
>> Tucker: BUT IT'S FAKE.
>> EVERYTHING ABOUT HIM IS FAKE.
HE JUST SHOWED HIS TRUE COLORS.
HOW CAN ANYBODY COME WITH
EVERYTHING GOING ON, HE BLAMES
ON DARYL MOREY?
THIS IS A REAL ISSUE.
THIS IS REALLY HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS GOING ON AND HE IS
TWEETING WELL, YOU MADE ME
UNCOMFORTABLE.
I DIDN'T GET A GOOD NIGHT SLEEP.
IT'S CRAZY.
>> Tucker: MOST PEOPLE, AS YOU
POINTED OUT, ARE SELLING
T-SHIRTS IN CHINA, YOU ARE
SELLING T-SHIRTS AGAINST
RENEGADE HOW MANY HAVE YOU SOLD?
>> A LOT.
DONALD TRUMP JR. READ TWEETED
THIS THE SECOND WE PUT THE SHIRT
ON SALE SO THAT CERTAINLY HELPS.
HE'S BECOMING LIKE A BARSTOOL
SUPER FAN WHICH IS GREAT.
WE SOLD A LOT.
I THINK WE ARE AT ABOUT 3,000 OF
THESE WERE SOLD PRETTY QUICKLY.
BY THE WAY, AGAIN, I'M GOING TO
BE FAIR, WE ACTUALLY HAD AN
ANTI-CHINA AND PRO-CHINA T-SHIRT
IN THE SAME BLOG.
BLUE STATES, RED STATES, THEY
BOTH BUY SHIRTS.
IT'S COMMUNIST, DEMOCRATS, THEY
WE WILL SELL THEM TO WHOEVER IS
BUYING.
>> Tucker: AND YOU'RE HONEST